Jonathan Metzel I'm associate professor
of psychiatry and women's studies and
director of the program and culture
health and medicine at the University of
Michigan
so basically I have a split appointment
at the University of Michigan the
majority of my time is spent teaching
graduate and undergraduate courses on
the history of psychiatry the history of
medicine and also on gender and race
politics in the United States I also
work as a psychiatrist at the University
so I also am an attending psychiatrist
in the outpatient psychiatry clinic and
I work in the psychiatric emergency room
and other other treatment sites
in terms of present-day psychiatry I
mean as you mentioned there have been
changes with every new version of the
DSM the Diagnostic and Statistical
Manual that have come out that have
sharpened our understanding of what
schizophrenia is and so in the present
day we think of schizophrenia as an
illness that yeah the main symptoms are
delusions hallucinations mostly hearing
voices sometimes seeing things at kind
of losing touch with reality also
paranoia feeling like people are out to
get you and social withdrawal what are
called negative symptoms a cognitive
cognitive withdrawal social withdrawal
so it's a very debilitating very serious
mental illness but as you mentioned this
definition has changed over time and
it's also changed in relation to
changing popular perceptions about how
people with schizophrenia act
book that's in part the story I tell is
how changing psychiatric definitions of
schizophrenia and changing american
cultural definitions of schizophrenia
really have morphed in relation to each
other over time and particularly in
relation to histories about race in the
United States so one of the central
narratives of the book is that in
particularly that early 1920s 1930s
1940s when the idea of schizophrenia
itself was first coming to the United
States from Europe there was a general
assumption that persons who suffered
from schizophrenia were either shy or
calm or they were geniuses it was often
represented as an illness that afflicted
white novelists or poets and as I say
these these were very often in popular
and psychiatric representing
representation assumed to be white
people now this was a you know a kind of
a gross generalization but in part what
was happening was that the illness
itself was defined almost as a
personality disorder like a split
personality so it was taken up by
psychoanalysts used in psychoanalytic
sessions and popular representation
really picked that up two instances from
this time period that I think are very
important one is a film that came out in
1948 called the snake pit which was an
olivia de havilland movie from made from
a book several years earlier of the same
name and it really showed schizophrenia
as being an illness that afflicted a
white a particular white middle-class
woman also when early versions of the
diagnostic manual came out in the early
1950s it really was it was called at
that time schizophrenic reaction and was
assumed to be mostly a personality
personality condition all of a sudden in
the 1960s American culture newspapers
magazines movies start to represent
angry african-american men as in part
being inflicted with a new form of this
particular illness so in the book I show
some drug ads for exam
that actually show pictures of urban
riots and race riots and the streets and
talk about how really the illness
assumptions about the illness change and
the other key thing that happens in the
1960s is that the official psychiatric
definition changes all of a sudden in
1968 the second version of the
diagnostic manual comes out and there's
new language that says aggression
hostility projection this is all added
to the definition of paranoid
schizophrenia and what I show is that
those terms were preferentially used not
only to talk about these new kinds of
patients african-american men but also
to change our ideas about how violent
people with schizophrenia are how
hostile they were how they might act
which led to a lot of fear
even the people who we
think of as being problematic in a way
doctors who were at that point over
diagnosing schizophrenia and
african-american men I found so I mean
the drug ads I would say are and I
invite people to look at the images
they're there in the book they're
expressed I mean I don't know what the
people were thinking at the time but
they were just problematically racist
and I think it's hard not to look at
those ads and see that anything else and
but in general I think that many of the
doctors and the sources that I look at
we're actually trying to help people
they were using the new state-of-the-art
diagnostic criteria that were coming
from their profession and I found
relatively few examples of people
actually trying to hurt people what they
were saying was oh here's a new
definition of illness that we can apply
to people and I think a lot of the
changes were happening as you suggest at
a much bigger level institutional levels
structural levels the level of the kind
of cultural unconscious in a way that
was shifting have we thought about these
people so you know a few examples from
the hospital I looked at I tell the
story of different groups of patients
through through the book project and
some of the key people I talked about
were african-american men and let me
just back up first and say that this was
a hospital the Ionia State Hospital for
the criminally insane that is or war was
about three hours north of Detroit and
it's kind of a central part of the story
I tell because in the 1920s 30s 40s 50s
the census listed the majority of
patients in the hospital as being
members of a category called us white
and most of the patients were from the
rural Midwest about thirty percent of
the hospital were women and there were
assumptions that these patients were
especially patients with schizophrenia
were not particularly violent so they
would take these people out on field
trips bring them to the state fair have
them go and interact with the community
all of a sudden in the 1950s and really
the 1960s you see increasing numbers
African American men brought to the
hospital from Detroit for various
reasons some had committed crimes some
had participated in civil rights
protests some had been participants in
urban riots at the time they all passed
through various forms of the penal
system and ended up diagnosed with
schizophrenia and locked into
psychiatric wards and so it was a very
complicated question for me how did
these men end up diagnosed with
schizophrenia was it because of some
inherent illness was it because of their
participation in anti-government
protests was it because they had been
abused in the prison system I found
evidence for all three of those
narratives but what was interesting was
the earlier people the women who had
been diagnosed with schizophrenia we're
all read iagnosed as suffering from
depression or bipolar disorder and a lot
of them were let go actually in the
deinstitutionalization movement but many
of the men who had been part of these
protests actually ended up staying in
even as the hospital itself changed into
something where security was much more
of an issue and you see the hospital
itself develop more and more fences
barbed wire moats and actually at the
end of the story I tell the hospital
itself becomes a prison in 1977 and
functioned for about the next three
decades as a medium security prison so
it really was this transformation not
just in assumptions about schizophrenia
but about how we think about people with
schizophrenia as being initially kind of
docile and harmless to being threats and
in fact threats that needed to be in
prisons in addition to psychiatric
hospitals
basically the central argument of the
book is that there was a transformation
in popular and medical and psychiatric
understandings of schizophrenia that
happened in the 1960s in relation to
certain responses different kinds of
responses to the civil rights era and to
the tensions of the civil rights
movement at the time and I show pretty
pretty directly how civil rights
politics civil rights anxieties other
kinds of things really shaped our
understanding of insanity in this
country and one part of that narrative
is that as I was mentioning before we we
developed at that time and a belief that
schizophrenia was an illness that was
increasingly marked by anger hostility
projection and even though that's not
part of the diagnosis anymore you see
the origin in the 1960s of a set of
stigmatization of people with with
schizophrenia in particular as being
violent that rose throughout the latter
half of the 20th century even after they
were associated with race all of a
sudden this initially this was a
category that was applied to these angry
protesting african-american men but you
see a broadening of this stigma to the
point where it came to apply to all
persons who suffer from schizophrenia
and their great research studies that
actually come from feeling and linked to
sociologists here at Columbia that show
that even though Americans have actually
grown more accepting of particular
mental illnesses stigma against
depression obsessive-compulsive disorder
anxiety have all gone down over the last
50 years stigma against schizophrenia
particularly as being violent has risen
over this same time period and i think
this history tells us tells us why so
one after effect of this period is
stigma of skit against schizophrenia is
being violent a second thing we see in
in the aftermath of this history is a
literature that's called the
misdiagnosis or over diagnosis of
schizophrenia in minority population
particularly black men a third area
which I can talk about in a bit if you
wish is the criminalization of mental
illness and this assumption that people
with schizophrenia are threats to the
state in a certain kind of way but
there's a flip side to the story as well
which is that schizophrenia was also a
metaphor a term a linguistic usage that
was taken up within civil rights
discourse itself I have a few chapters
where I talk about how schizophrenia
became a term that Martin Luther King
used in seven or eight of his main
sermons and in a bunch of his writings
and for King schizophrenia was an
illness that it actually wasn't an
illness what he said was there's
schizophrenia literally means split mind
and he said there's a split and in our
minds between good and evil dark and
light and what we need to do is choose
the path of nonviolent resistance
schizophrenia was also a term that was
taken up by leaders of the nation of
islam Black Power movement Malcolm X was
himself miss diagnosed with
schizophrenia and a CIA file I talked
about that in the book many of the
leaders used schizophrenia but what they
said is it's not an illness of the black
mind instead schizophrenia is a response
to the illness of white of white racism
that basically this is a justifiable
means of fighting back against white
society and it's interesting for me what
I do is track through that particular
usage and show how that didn't disappear
and part of the way I get to that is to
look at present day uses of mental
illness terms in rap and hip-hop and
popular cultural music so toward the end
of the book I do a mini research project
where I look at lyrics databases and
first what I do is look for terms like
depression or depressed across all
american popular music and what you find
is that terms like depression and
depressed show up in the lyrics of
people like America stick Celine Dion
Joni Mitchell the Eagles you know kind
of what you might call white crooning
a certain kind of way I hate to over
generalize but it's very often assumed
to be a particular mood disorder but if
you go into the same databases and you
type in the word schizophrenic
schizophrenia or schizophrenic as I
talked about in the book on I list
references to over 200 rap or hip-hop
artists who the artists are actually
calling them scouts else elves
schizophrenic Tupac shaam other artists
and basically what they say is yeah I'm
schizophrenic and I'm violent and I'm
hostile and I'm a threat to your to you
or to other rappers or to the police or
to the state and you better get out of
my way and it's really interesting to
say why would this mental illness term
show up in hip-hop right and on one hand
which I think would be wrong is to say
well they're taking psychiatric usage in
a way and saying I'm just crazy or
something like that which isn't part
true but for me it's actually saying
this history why this usage is actually
coming from an earlier tradition it's
coming right out of the usage in black
power in the 1960s basically saying
hostility is a response to structural
violence and I'm going to assume this
identity as a way of fighting back and
so it's interesting that it remains a
protest identity in this particular
forum
really one of the things I really try to
do very consciously in the book is to
track a particular evolution of that
process and part of what I show is that
even though we had all these asylums in
the 1930s and 40s and 50s where we
locked away all of these people there
was this and often for long periods of
time but not always there was this
assumption that we were kind of treating
people in a certain kind of way that
there was a possible recuperation or
cure obviously didn't happen for a lot
of people but you know there was an
investment I mean people were being
locked away but they were also seen as
responsibilities particularly in
schizophrenia of the state and and part
of what happens with this definitional
and racial change in the way
schizophrenia is understood in the 60s
is a feeling that these people aren't
just docile dependence of the state
they're also threats to the state
particularly with schizophrenia you see
a lot of concern that these people could
escape and kill people or they could
threaten our political order and
particularly in the 1960s when
schizophrenia becomes linked to civil
rights protests it's also schizophrenia
can bring down the state and in a very
you know this has happened in other
country so it's not surprising but we
don't often think about that in the
United States but I think part of why
schizophrenia got linked to civil rights
protest in the 60s was because
mainstream society was coding threats
against the smooth running of the state
as insanity and treating it as such and
so as that happens you see the evolution
of a process in which people with
schizophrenia are increasingly feared
and our hospitals that particularly the
kind of hospital that I look at in the
book become to look more and more like
like prisons to the point where many of
them including the one I talked about
actually become prisons and that's
something that didn't just happen near
Detroit where I look but across the
country according to Human Rights Watch
for example in the present day if you
are person diagnosed with schizophrenia
renia and you are in a state institution
your chances are exponentially greater
that institution is going to be prison
rather than a hospital Bernard Harcourt
a law professor at the University of
Chicago talks about the transformation
from a hospital-based institution to a
prison based institution and it's
something that happened across the
country and that happened obviously for
many reasons but part of it is this
transformation in which prisons became
our de facto mental hospitals and we saw
mental illness as in some way
threatening not just to the people who
suffered from it but also to us
mainstream society
right well I you know again I'm a
practicing psychiatrist and I think that
I really believe in the advances of
psychiatry our diagnoses are more
precise they get more precise with every
volume of the diagnostic manual our
treatments slowly get better over time
and I'm not adverse to saying that there
are biological basis to mental illness
I'm part of a department that does a lot
of fantastic research in brain imaging
scans other kinds of genetic research
that really looks at mental illness
seemingly below the level of culture
context race ethnicity at the level of
brain structures that are seemingly the
same in all people and at the same time
I feel like there's a false divide
almost like you have to vote is an
illness biological or is it social or
socially constructed and I I don't like
that divide very much because I think
that all definitions of illness and may
be particularly all definitions of
psychiatric illness are always are
always both it doesn't have to be one of
the other mental illness is a real thing
it has real material consequences for
people who suffer from it and at the
same time even the most biological
finding reflects social social context
in very important ways and so I think
psychiatry is better off looking both at
biology and at social context and really
trying to think of the relationship
between those and I think doctors and
patients are better off that way we
certainly know that depression is an
illness all you have to do is watch it
antidepressant advertisement on
television right now and think about why
might it be that a person might see an
ad like that what are the forces that
are leading them to go in and ask a
doctor in part in part it might be that
that ad speaks to some symptoms they're
having that are chemical symptoms but
you many of these ads play off of
familiar cultural stereotypes about
gender or parenting or social class
other kinds of things and so I think
doctors need to be aware of both that
depression as one example is an illness
that has a chemical basis but also is
deeply embedded in cultural norms about
gender social class race so that would
be one example there's great work that's
been done now on bipolar disorder by
emily martin here at nyu and looking at
the kind of cultural basis of bipolar
disorder obsessive-compulsive disorder
after the show monk for instance is
something that there's a lot of popular
conversation about and so i think again
it's true for all illness but it's
certainly true for psychiatric illness
that these illnesses often reflect
cultural norms in addition to biological
realities and really we have to be
fluent in both
well again I think that we're we're
making a mistake if we don't see that
there's a cultural basis too many
illnesses not just psychiatric ones
breast cancer would be one prevalent
example right now different kind of
culture surrounding it if you don't
understand the cultural meaning of an
illness like that you're going to you're
going to miss the boat even if you are a
great scientist um so I don't think it's
the case that it's just psychiatric
disorders but we know from history that
when we get the ultimate you know cure
for a particular illness or nail it down
it stops being a psychiatric illness and
then it's taken up by internal medicine
or you know we know oh it was just an
iron imbalance or it was a vitamin
deficiency or something like that that
in a way it's taken away from psychiatry
and taken taken to medicine but but I
think that's a you know if you look at
diagnostic rates and treatment rates in
psychiatric disorders it's even with all
the controversy about SSRIs right now
the improvement rates are reasonably
good compared to other medical
specialties and so I think it's it's
always going to be a negotiation about
what's the best way to understand
psychiatric illness but of course the
flip side of that is that there is this
aura of it's something we don't know in
a certain kind of way and so psychiatry
is always kind of fighting against that
and probably that's why we had a move
toward saying things are solely
biological in a certain kind of way is
to you know rightly move toward a more
scientific basis
terrific well I mean it's it's there are
really exciting things happening in
genetics and neurobiology right now and
really looking at the ways in which
difference not just illnesses but social
conditions and social pressures can
actually lead to actual brain changes
you know there was a lot of promise in
the development of pharmaceuticals
particularly with the advent of newer
generation of anti psychotics and anti
depressants and we know from history
that there's a kind of natural
trajectory of the way that these on't
that these medications come out and and
are accepted so initially we say these
are cures for everything under the Sun
and there's this dramatic rise and then
we say wait a minute these don't work
for anything which i think is happening
with the SSRI antidepressants right now
and then we kind of figure out a
moderated use of well they're good for
some conditions and not for others and
so again as I say I think that there's a
a give-and-take that's part of the
process and part of it is based in
science but I also think you know the
1990s were often called the decade of
the brain and psychiatry where we didn't
need to worry about Freud or about
gender psychoanalysis context all these
things were in certain ways kind of
pitched out the window because we were
going to get the answer to everything
from brain scans and I think psychiatry
itself has come to in a way like
medications a more moderated
understanding of the brain itself is
very important but you don't really know
anything at the brain unless you know
about social context expectations stigma
as other kinds of things and so
hopefully these findings will continue
to be understood in in social contexts